when I was a kid I told you drugs didn't
really attract me at all with one
exception I was curious about
LSD and mushrooms and people now today
are always talking about Ayahuasca and
all these the psychedelics interested me
and I never did them I kind of had a
little bit of a fear of them because I
was told when you do it your brain is
never the same it kind of rewires you
and I thought well I don't know I kind
of rely on my brain so I don't know that
I want to rewire it but I was
curious about I said what could I see if
I took these drugs so when did you
graduate to those kinds of drugs um
so when I got into high school about 14
you know I got I saw the movie uh the
doors
um Jim Morrison with Val Kilmer and man
I never felt like I related to somebody
so much like like when I was watching
him I felt like I was watching the
person I wanted to be or something in
that movie so much of me connected with
it
and so uh he was doing peyote and acid
and stuff in the movie and so at some
point in high school I had a friend get
have acid
and I did it and it wasn't like I didn't
I didn't take enough I don't think
nothing really happened but I felt kind
of just different but nothing really
happened and then a few months later uh
or yeah like probably the next year I
think it was like 10 much sophomore year
high school
I had mushrooms and so the mushrooms I
was sitting in somebody's car and
it was like a it was like weed all over
again it was just a whole new reality
I'm saying you know and I spent like
three hours you know back in the day it
was like the CD players had the little
um pictures on them and like you could
pop them in and out and as for three
hours I was just sitting there staring
at that you know like that like it just
got me entrenched into this like this
new reality and I'm like look up I'm
with my friend and it's like dude we've
been doing this for four hours having
the time of our life it was just it was
just so intense I I had this experience
of just feeling like there was uh like
the universe was alive like I felt
connected to the things that were around
me I felt like I was connected to life
um in a different way and I started
thinking different I got more I guess
deep in my thought I started just kind
of becoming more philosophical and and
you know my approach to just how I was
viewing things in my perspective and so
it was like
how
is it different in in that
I go through my daily life I I feel that
the world is teeming with life I mean I
I feel connected all the things you're
describing I feel that in my ordinary
day-to-day life you you describe the
sense of going deeper or thinking more
philosophically and I don't so I don't
have experience of the mushrooms but I
think I've I read a book and I think
more philosophically where I look at a
work of art and I
so how what was different about the
all of that on the mushrooms
I don't know if I could say that it was
more of it slowed everything down and
made me more like it was like oh look at
this water like and you notice every
little bubble it just like made you so
appreciative of the moment pulled me
into the moment in such a way where I
appreciate things I never appreciated
before and then there was this feeling
of just Joy like I couldn't stop
laughing I had you know I mean I was
laughing the whole time and I had the
time in my life
um
and so it just at that point I was
hooked like it was like I can't wait to
ever do this again
um and then what happened was I actually
went to a rehab not like a month after
that I went away for for a year in a
rehab and in that rehab I got into
Buddhism
and so when I started to read about
Buddhism and and taoism and stuff it
started to meditate I started to notice
that the the ideology behind it was
lining up with the ideology I was kind
of having on the mushrooms
so it was like this you know there was
this dynamic between them that started
to kind of cross many such cases by the
way my friends who have gotten into
shrooms and acid and stuff they have
gone down that sort of Buddhist Taoist
Eastern mystical route so you you end up
in the rehab was it a family member or
something sent you there or yeah yeah my
parents because my mom you know she on
her side of the family there was a lot
of addiction my dad's side of the family
that had alcoholism so they were just
being good parents you know they see
their kids falling down that hole um so
they were just trying to help you know
right and um but the thing is is I was
you know I was 15 and when you're 15 you
think you know everything you don't want
hope I in my mind I'm like I'm just
smoking weed
um you know my I try to ecstasy pill or
something a couple of things but in my
mind everyone else I was with was doing
the same stuff so I didn't think it was
you know absurd or anything
um and so when I went to the rehab I had
gotten into to Buddhism
um
and while I was there I think because I
didn't have a family and because I
didn't have I'm just with a bunch of
kids and from all over the country that
I don't know
um the place got shut down for child
abuse so it's like I'm with you know
wacko people leading it
um
and I think I felt like I didn't I I
only had myself it was like the first
time in my life it was like you're on
your own kind of thing you know that's
how it felt was like all you have is
yourself to to rely on and so Buddhism
kind of uh it it taught me I guess how
to kind of be strong Within Myself And
it taught me the power of like what was
within me and it taught you know what I
mean and so I I just took to it and I
got addicted to it um you know because I
was on a ADHD medicine at the time and
so that you know gives you hyper focus
and all that and uh so I just that's all
there was nothing else to do I mean I'm
stuck in this place for a year
um
and so that's all I did I started
meditating and reading books and yeah
and you you found that there was a
commonality in the perspective on the
world did you find there was a common
effect you know did you get the same
sort of high by meditating in this
Buddhist manner
um
I wouldn't say to that extreme or to
that extent
um
but I started meditating and I started
having
um moments where I would get something
that would remind me of it and I'll give
you an example like there would be
moments where I'd feel like I would
start kind of vibrating or something or
um
I would just feel like this this Divine
connection that reminded me of when I
was on the mushroom so it was it was
like these moments of it but the
difference was like I felt like I had to
work for it so with the mushrooms that
you take this and you stay there you
rest there but with the Buddhism it was
like you're doing this stuff I'm
meditating I'm you know to get to that
place and then try to stay there um so
what you're describing
sounds generally Pleasant I don't know
that it sounds like an ultimate uh
Triumph for Joy or Victory but at least
it sounds kind of pleasant you're just
vibing you know feeling with the
universe man and so
How does it go wrong oh man well so
that's kind of that's I mean that's a
long story this we're talking like a
decade of of Journey to find that out um
so after the rehab when I came home
I got my first legal trouble
um so when I got my first legal trouble
I was 16. I got put on probation
um I wouldn't stop smoking weed I I you
know I'm actually friends with my
probation officer to this day you know
on social media and stuff and so she was
really cool towards me but I kept
smoking we and I told her I said I'm not
gonna stop you know I said if you unlock
me I've been locked me and so I was
going in and out of juvie like you know
I'd fail my urine test and then I'd go
for like 30 days two weeks whatever and
then eventually I said you know what I
gotta find something else and so uh one
day I was on house arrest with my friend
and he asked me he had a painkiller
and uh he he asked me if I wanted to try
it with him me and him had never done it
together before so I did the painkiller
and um it was just it was like the same
thing again it was like this this
feeling I never had the best feeling I
ever had in my life me and him looked at
each other and we're like do you feel
that and um
and so that began basically within six
months I was shooting up heroin so whoa
so at that point
um psychedelics were always there as
like a here and there thing
um there was something I just enjoyed
um but then at one point I guess
probably
Maybe
10 years into it it's I'm trying to like
do the math in my head of like time
frames around 19 like 20
um psychedelics were
they were something that I did when I
was I needed heroin to function
basically right so like the heroin was
that was my addiction but the
psychedelics at that point they started
off in high school as like a party thing
it's like you go to the party you have
fun you laugh but I knew the spiritual
element was there and so once I got uh
to the place of like liking Buddhism and
stuff like that I started taking them to
kind of jump into the the spiritual
aspect of it so I would take them and so
I had nothing but good experiences you
know like I had nothing but positive
things happening as far as I would have
this like new profound wisdom would hit
me I'd have this understanding of being
connected being one uh all of us loving
each other it was like that's the secret
to life uh love each other you know um
is there any
was there any wisdom perhaps that is the
wisdom but is
is there anything you remember now
looking back on it ah yes here was a bit
of wisdom that I gleaned on one of these
trips that I wouldn't have known
otherwise is there anything you can
point to and say ah that piece of wisdom
or no was it just kind of a feeling of
wisdom no I think it was just more of
just a different mindset it was like
just a different level of Consciousness
that when I was in that place everything
made sense so it's like it was all and
it's like the funny thing about
hallucinogens is like uh a lot of the
stuff you forget it's like you're here
and then it like leaves you and that's
why people keep oh you know I need to go
do another Retreat I mean because it's
like I know it was great and I know I
learned a lot yeah I just don't remember
anything I learned yeah and you take
some of it with you you'll take like one
or two things and then the rest is
forgotten and um so that's what it was
it was like
um like in an example was like I always
would walk away with this feeling like I
need to be a better person like it would
it would crush my my ego and Crush my my
pride in the moments you'd get you know
I mean and I would I'd be like man I'm
really a bad son I'm I'm really you know
I mean like I'm a bad brother you know
I'm saying like I would have these these
real like I guess reflective moments and
so because of that I'm thinking this
must be a good thing because it's it's
bringing I guess uh sobriety to my
thinking in a way you know I mean it's
it's making me see things different
whereas other drugs they feed that
selfishness it's like that heroin you
don't care about anybody but on
psychedelics I'd be like oh I need to be
more mindful of other people stuff like
well I've been around people who have
been on coke and they're the most
annoying people on planet Earth they
never shut up they're talking about the
most boring things ever for some reason
they always are trying to get you to do
Coke I've been offered cocaine so many
times in my life and I've never done it
it's not not something that's interested
me but I thought isn't this expensive
like why are you trying to Peddle your
expensive drug on me why are you talking
about your work assignment from last
Thursday nobody cares just like they're
babbling it anyway anyway I I could see
that distinction between a drug that
kind of pulls you out of yourself much
as Buddhism does Buddhism is essentially
a denial of the self and and a drug that
pulls you really into yourself but so
what you're describing
other than your life completely falling
apart while you're doing it yeah other
than that little detail it sounds like
the hallucinogens are fine
yeah it seemed that way and so I thought
they were the answer yeah so my whole
life goal was I just need to trip like I
wanted a perma-trip that was my goal you
hear these these horror stories there's
this story that goes around everyone
says I know this guy who thought he was
a cup of orange juice yeah right right
like everyone's heard this story and
somehow it's like their friend he thinks
he's a banana he peels himself off yeah
you know it's and I would I I honestly
at the time was I was jealous of that
like not not that outcome but the the
outcome of like I could stay in this
place because I like again I liked who I
was in that that state and so um it was
always like I just need to go trip one
more time
um collect the data and then remember it
and stay there and um and so the the
other thing was like so the there was
positive things when I started getting
into DMT where I was having encounters
with light beings you know what I mean
I'm having they're they're talking to me
they're telling me you need to stop
doing heroin or you're gonna die they're
guiding me in a positive way
but at the same time I'm getting more
into the occult I'm playing Ouija boards
thinking it's a game I'm egging on like
the Ouija board move and I'm telling it
you know show yourself that you know I'm
egging it on I'm thinking it's all joke